वैसे तुम्हें यादे आज क्या है?
आज का दिन कैसे बोल सकता हूँ?
बदकिस्मती से आज का दिन तुमसे मेरी शादी हो गई थी
तुप भी ना, मजाग करना कब चोड़ोगे?
चलो मैं आफिस के लिए लेट हो रहा हूँ
सलाम साहब, आपने जो पैसे दिये थे ना, इलाज के लिए, उससे मेरा भाई बच गया
आज वाले डील हास से नहीं जाने देंगे
हाँ, जब से तुम जैसा पार्टनर मेरी कंपनी में है, मैं कोई भी डील हास से नहीं जाने दूँगा
अरे साहब, कैसी रही गोआ की ट्रिफ?
कौन गया गोआ?
पिछले हफ़ते तो आप गये थे
पागल है क्या? कुछ भी बोले जा रहा है
अरे, आ गया आप?
पता नहीं कार्ट को क्या हो गया?
कह रहा है, पिछले हफ़ते मैं गोआ गया था
मैं कैसी चीज़ें भूल सकता हूँ?
लेकिन गए तो थे आप
तुम भी पागल हो गयी हो क्या?
अरे यार, पता नहीं क है, बागल हो गया है
कह रहे हैं, मैं पिछले हफ़ते गोआ गया था
तु पिसले अपने गुआ गया तो था
तु भी बागल हो गया है क्या
ये देख फोटोस तेरी गुआ की
तुमने मेरे जीने के अजादी चीन रखी थी
हमने थोड़ा सा पैसा क्या मांग दिया था
तुमने तो मुझे अपना गुलाम समझ लिया
तो गलत तो मेरे साथ भी बहुत कुछ हुआ है
इसलिए हम सबने मिलके तुमारे दिमाग से खेलने का प्लेन बनाया
और तुम हार गए
तो हमें बदला लेना पड़ा